I used mean I used to have all those
default positions that people have you
know big oil companies are evil you know
McDonald's is evil Starbucks somehow
something bad you know I know you know
it's kind of us it's kind of a lazy it's
kind of a lazy position to have if
you're concentrating a lock on drinking
beer and partying you know and it's kind
of like fine you know I'll go along with
all that and save the whale and whatever
just I don't want to wear the sandals or
get facial hair so glad to have this
next guest here in LA doroth Crowder
when I have sub hosted other shows I've
always had this lady on one of the
creators of the GoFundMe campaign
actually created for the film Gosnell
movie.com the most successful IndieGoGo
independently funded film ever of course
about the crazy abortion doctor has done
so much good work on the side of climate
change frac nation as a film I highly
recommend you watch thrilled to have an
McElhenney did I get that right on the
program brilliant yes and it's great to
be here thank you Steve and we're so
glad to have you on and so what's funny
is what what started this was I got an
email so let's start with this you did
frack nation of course which is a
rebuttal to gas land for those who are
listening to rest truly go to LA to
Earth crater comm will have the links
watching on YouTube will have an
annotation propaganda film you did frack
nation and I see you this link that
someone sent me of a guy in front of a
city or state legislature daring them to
drink
fracking solution water but it's a
gimmick that caught a bunch of traction
with the left and I knew it was BS so I
figured you could give me a clear answer
let's start off with that yeah you know
one of the things I talk to groups about
fracking all the time and I go around
the country and one of the one of the my
kind of sticks is who are these people
who are these anti frakkers you know
I'll tell you who they are Steven these
are people who lied about breast cancer
so this is the kind of person we're
dealing with here these are people who
made a film called the sky is pink the
same man who made Gasland put out a film
it's on the internet where he said that
in the area around Fort Worth's in Texas
a very heavy development area for
fracking that there was arrived that
there was a rise in breast cancer you
know something when
people start mentioning breast cancer a
cancer in general we're all kind of all
the laughs are done we're all very
serious none of us have escaped
none of us haven't got a family member
who's died because of cancer and guess
who these people are that guy you know
who he's part of he's part of people who
lied about that and it's not an opinion
is the Texas Cancer Registry said it's
nonsense there is no evidence of that
there is no spike in breast cancer in
the fourth word Fort Worth area and this
is who these people are this is what
they do and I mean we make a bit of a
laugh about it because every day they
accuse fracking of doing something else
you know you know I've got eczema my
husband doesn't fancy me the donkey died
the donkey didn't die I wish the donkey
would I you know I've got a funny H I've
got a funny this but then they're kind
of funny I'm serious about it and they
say things like cancer these are liars
these are bad people here's the truth
fracking is a miracle um you know it's
just extraordinary you know like you
know what do we need we really need
energy and the absence of it is death
and guess what we're not doing debt
Steven we're not wanting death who wants
that
you know when places where they live an
organic lifestyle and have no energy
people live to be 40 if they're lucky so
you know my father died at 95 I think
energy is a great thing and we want more
of it and reliable energy solar panels
are great wind great I'm all in favor of
all of it it just doesn't work right now
so in the mean time when we've got our
children in hospitals we want reliable
energy and you know we're going to get
that from oil and gas it's reckless and
cold by the way sure I'm all for that
but I wish the people who were against
fracking would just be honest just tell
the truth and it's really disturbing to
find that they were like real quick like
breast cancer real quick you have been
paid by big oil correct yeah all the
people who paid me can you can find them
you can look at them you can look at
them and find their names we did a
crowdfunding campaign for frack nation
we got over almost a quarter more than a
quarter million dollars I think Graham's
about 3,000 people and all their names
in there so you can look them all up
ordinary people from around the country
and around the world 26 countries I
think it is they contributed regular
folk that's who made the film and we're
so grateful to them for doing that it's
an incredible film by the way I mean
it's one of those films
we're I mean you know with shows and
promos and your husband is such a sweet
guy I was like oh yeah and I had seen it
at all the C packs but not the full
thing and then when I finally sat down
and watched the whole film
I called him right away I said fill them
you have to tell me how I can help with
this is an unreal my wife watched it all
the way through and she usually gets
bored to tears with these things it's
one of those deals where you guys don't
just do the sting you know though oh we
got you you look stupid
you actually educate the audience and
really get to the bottom of the issue
with fracking which is jobs saving lives
basically a death sentence for people in
third-world countries
now your transition was interesting a
lot of people don't know this you
weren't always this way tell our
listeners who might not know how you
came to be on this path I like to say to
people you know I used to be a liberal
but I'm okay now so I used to mean I
used to have all those default positions
that people have you know big oil
companies are evil you know McDonald's
evil Starbucks somehow something bad you
know and I know you know it's kind of us
it's kind of a lazy it's kind of a lazy
position to have if you're concentrating
a lock on drinking beer and partying you
know and it's kind of like fine you know
I'll go along with all that and save the
whale and whatever just I don't want to
wear that the sandals or get a facial
hair but you know I kind of was that
kind of person and then you know I I
started work I was living in Romania my
husband was a correspondent for the
Financial Times and I was a freelance
journalist just doing whatever stories
would come up and the story came up
about a gold mine in Transylvania you
know which actually exists and yes
Dracula did did live there for a time
and and you know we went up to cover the
story and we had a story written before
we went there we hadn't written in our
heads you know obviously evil gold
mining company Canadian evil gold mining
company innocent locals innocent natives
being taken advantage of and it was just
one of those really weird things where
we should start
asking people questions and we spoke to
the people from Greenpeace we spoke to
the locals we spoke to the evil
Canadians and found out that the story
that was being reported by the BBC by
the New York Times by CNN it was
nonsense right first of all the locals
loved the mine
the mine was had
had surpassed all standards for
environmental rules everyone was in
favor of it except for two foreigners
foreign environmentalists and the locals
basically the village was dying without
the mine and I just I came I went up a
mountain one way and I came down another
and the kind of the moment that really
galvanized me was I'm at an 86 year old
woman who was living it was who had come
to visit a model house that the
Canadians had built and said look if you
give us your house you can live in a
house like this and she was crying and
she said and I thought oh here's our
story here's the woman who's being
abused by the Canadian nice little quick
so go ahead what's your problem I said
boy why are you crying and she said I
hope I live long enough to live in a
house like this she didn't because of
two foreign environmentalists
heartbreaking what will bring you back
and then we'll have a laugh on something
else
McIlhenny a lot of us Crowder so glad to
have MS Ann McIlhenny back Gosnell movie
calm please go donate they do great work
we were talking during the break my wife
was calling my phone was blowing up if
you heard it on air our dog is a little
bit sick and it's actually a dog who's
banned a breed that is banned over there
in the UK I'm not a big fan of those
breed bans I'm terrible I don't know why
I don't know much about dogs I'd like to
have one when I grow up well he's a dog
argentino and so they look at him and I
think he's you know like a pit bull had
a baby with a nightmare he's just huge
but they actually send them out they
hunt in packs with dogs so they're not
bred for fighting at all they're
actually very very dog friendly very
people obedient but very animal
aggressive like cats or squirrels he
just he cannot stand but otherwise he's
the gentlest dog going and can't have
one of them in the UK again because
government doesn't get the full story
they decide we're gonna breed bans but
ban breeds so before you left okay we
were talking about frack nation you gave
us some some information on us it's
important but I wanted to talk about
this one specific video that's
circulating where this guy goes in front
of some municipal legislature and says
hey do you guys want to drink this
fracking water so I thought oh okay
here's some proof that fracking did
Taman eighths water he's just going to
pour some water from his faucet and tell
him to drink it because everyone was
sending this like wildfire that's the
title people you know city officials or
state officials won't drink fracking
water but what he does is he takes a cup
of perfectly good water and then adds a
bunch of chemicals into the water mixes
it up and goes ooh uh-huh well you drink
that you drink that
I don't exactly know why that's BS I'm
pretty sure that's not how fracking
works and correct me yeah I mean the
fracking fluid is 99% water then there's
a percentage of sand basically are
corrosive so that they can you know so
when they're doing this fracking which
is putting this liquid at a very high
pressure down into the Earth's that it
can actually you know corrode and make
you know release the car the
hydrocarbons and there are chemicals
there are chemicals by the way in the
fracking fluid you know water itself of
course is a chemical but not a lot of
people know about and and there are
chemicals a lot of the chemicals that
are in fracking fluid are the kind of
things that you'd find under your
kitchen sink and you're not alarmed
about you know there's things like this
guar which is an element that's used in
ice cream making actually powders and
stuff like that too it's like absolutely
absolutely and you know if you were to
eat any of those elements you know a
massive massive quantity of them and do
I need nothing else over time yeah you
probably would get cancer so they call
them carcinogenic but they're a tiny
tiny the amount of them is so tiny that
it couldn't do any damage I mean there
are carcinogens in cabbage but I those
kind of stunts by the way those stunts
of having this liquid and saying oh my
god would you drink this it's just very
cheap and it's theatrical it makes good
press but it's not honest this is not
honest Rand I don't understand why
people don't have an honest conversation
about this when we do need energy right
we do need energy well let me ask you
this so I want the environment to be to
be clean you know I don't think we
should be tossing all over McDonald's
cups out the window how would the
cleanliness of energy from say fracking
compared to the cleanliness of energy
extracted in oil fields let's say in
Saudi Arabia than transported to the
United States yeah well I mean obviously
there's pretty big carbon footprint in
that actually if you're going to be cut
transporting that all the way from Saudi
Arabia I you know the standards here the
environmental laws that exist here in
the United States far surpass any other
country in the world and certainly would
surpass Saudi Arabians environmental
standards so I don't understand why
we're not going for our own energy
source which is local organic indigenous
it's our it's it's you know it's right
here under the ground why aren't we
using our own
I can't understand you and we have used
it successfully and it's even funny here
in California you walk on a beach in
Santa Barbara and your feet go black and
it's not pollution that's so much oil
it's just seeping up through through the
sand we're meant to be using this really
is that now is that is that true am I
gonna go in my bed I tell you one thing
I'll tell you how weird it is Steven I
thought this was the funniest I was
asked to make a speech in Santa Barbara
and I put me in a very nice hotel thank
you very much well there are no no bad
hotels in San oh you're right in the
bathroom
I found a thing that I've never seen in
any bathroom anywhere in the world they
have a little thing in a packet and you
open it and it's for remote tire removal
to help you remove the tar from your
feet when you've walked on the sand
because your feet will be black and it's
really hard to get it off you know it's
funny that you mentioned that because I
remember when I was a kid I might have
been the fifth or sixth grade I had to
do some project this is in Canada of
course on saving the tar sands and I
didn't think anything of it and so I
wrote about you know the reason to save
the tar sands and then I were thinking
when I was in high school it was about
15 or 16 thinking how the hell do I care
about the tar since they're tar sands I
mean I get you know save the weeping
willows save the you know the endangered
German Shorthaired Sparrow I don't know
I'm making up terms I was when the tar
sands it would seem to me that a tar
sand would exist for no other purpose if
not to extract tar yeah yeah but also by
the way it's not the guitar set they're
called the oil sands but
environmentalists like to miss named
things as well just to try and make
people get very alarmed very didn't say
tar sands though I don't think I miss
sorry so yes they all say that's what
the environmentalists scene the
environmental movement calls them tar
sands okay but people in the oil and gas
business call him oil sands and it's
marvelous god canada what great how
great that our nearest neighbor who
don't be had women funny enough who
don't stone women funny enough that
those people would have this incredible
supply of oil yeah isn't that great and
they allow women to drive cars and
everything in Canada that's how weird
those Canadians are so I think getting
oil from them is a great idea you know
yeah no I think you're right I mean I
don't I don't
here's the truth and I've always talked
about this when people say the United
States is an evil English Empire I
okay I'm from Canada the fact that a
country like Canada one of the biggest
countries geographically I think it is
the biggest next to China in the world
one of the most rich in natural
resources with virtually no National
Defense whatsoever that they're allowed
to exist with America to the south is
proof that it cannot be in nowhere else
by the way in the history of the world
you go as far back as if there is a
country as rich in resources like Canada
and there's one world superpower like
the United States by two o'clock
canada's america that really makes sense
god the Canadians are lucky the other
place is very lucky is Australia it's
true Australia and Canada have a lot in
common very very rich countries with
very tiny populations yes except
Australia has all the rapists so they've
got a I mean when you're starting off
with the civilization of we I'm sorry
I'm sorry to the Australian listeners we
got so many Australians I will say this
it's the one place where you don't get
this rampant anti-american sentiment
that you get if a lot of places either
in Europe or my people are there people
have they been really accepting have you
noticed of your message and things like
that writing yeah not not quite quite
weird you know I've had some I've had
some very super aggressive
correspondence with people from Ireland
I have to say what is it about the Irish
that they don't like you I mean they you
know they seem to really embrace their
own if an Irish person makes it in the
States they tend to reclaim them as
their own yet they seem to not be doing
that with you no offense well I think
it's a it's a I think it's a liberal
issue it's rather than anything else I
think if I was if I was singing their
tune they'd like me a lot but I'm not
singing their tune so it's them it's a
bit aggressive well let me ask you this
what the Irish are there any actual
Conservatives in Ireland yes there are
yes there are but it's a small minority
sir well certainly it's not sorry that's
not right there obviously are lots of
conservatives in Ireland but they're not
represented at all in the media and the
media is predominantly like more than
predominantly liberals so people don't
even get to hear another story they just
get a very very biased version of the
news right well then it's very
restricted it's very it's very
restricted what to get access to it
makes me realize like how
incredible top radio waves here how
amazing that is that people have these
options and the fact that Fox News
exists here you know it's it's quite
amazing because you know otherwise
otherwise people are stuck with this
version of the world of ABC NBC CBS CBS
and what it and whatever they say just
goes and that's the only thing that
anyone ever hears about but the Internet
has done something very wonderful about
that that's absolutely true well hey if
we were still back in those days people
would believe that Brian Williams was
shot down in a helicopters oh just love
Brian I'm so happy by Bremen's I just
love and I love the idea that somebody
called super Mexican that's super
Mexican who I give a shout-out to the
other day like super Mexican really
brought down Brian Williams and Brian
Williams what the beautiful irony of
this is that Brian Williams was very
disparaging of people like super Mexican
who he described as Vinny in a Vinny in
a in a in a bathrobe in a sad bathrobe
and you know in an apartment in the in
the Bronx and he made he had this whole
thing about people these awful people on
Twitter and on social media yeah guess
what Brian Williams those people in
their bathrobes took away your 10
million dollar a year job because they
did a better job of investigating
journalism than you could do or than
anyone else could do that's a really
good point and do you feel like it's the
same thing I guess sort of in Reverse
with the environmentalism where if
someone comes out and says what you say
it's as opposed to Vinnie in the
bathrobe it's well this person is
someone who clearly works for big pharma
big oil or they're a part of the
Monsanto crew do you ever get a little I
mean I've never
the guy from frack nation is still never
actually acknowledged you guys and not
frack nation from gospel Gasland right
he still just really wants to avoid it
and I get that sometimes
you know I have certain people who I'm
like I'm not gonna debate with them
because you know you can't change minds
but you you're both very sensible has he
tried to do that with you and say that
you're paid off by somebody or what's
the dynamic there well I think it yeah I
mean I think that's that you know if
you've got nothing else to say then
that's a you know that's it that's a
good one throw that one at people and
see if it'll stick you know I mean yeah
he certainly has tried I think he said
that but at this 2-digit I'm weary with
it you know I'm weary with these people
who lived these lives fueled by oil and
gas and then denounced oil and gas he
flies around the world
he makes a big deal about how many
countries he travels to doesn't he wear
big plastic hipster glasses but totally
yeah so what under percent I know you
take away petroleum from that guy and
he'd be left naked with little leaf on
his front which yeah we're not even
going there Stephen no I think it I
think you'd be looking at more of an
acorn I think at that point when you've
ceased to be an act like a man for so
long that your nether regions just
shrivel up and die I want to get to
something here before we go to the break
and what we have to have you on for a
third segment but you said something
that stuck with me and I've tweeted it
out and I'm not an Oprah soundbite
person but you crystallized something
perfectly and you may not even
remembered it was that some college it
wasn't even like a giant crowd it was
something that most people would miss
and some girl was critiquing you talk
temple in Philadelphia go and she's
mentioned you know the scientific
consensus and you said something that
was brilliant that science is not
governed by consensus look how about you
say it we've got one and a half minutes
for you to say this yeah I mean a lot of
the people in the Chloe the climate
alarmists sites say things like this
it's all settled it's all done it's all
so the science is settled everyone
agrees 97% of scientists agree I said
that never science has never works like
that it's never worked by committee the
boiling point of water is not a
committee decision you and I can't get a
12 guys together in a room and make an
agreement about about and say things
that's gonna be how gravity works from
now on it doesn't work like that so this
idea that a great number of people
agreeing with something will affect
what's what the truth is in science it's
utter nonsense it's not a democracy
science is not a democracy truth is not
a democracy one person saying that the
that the earth is not flat was there was
the right guy the consensus was that the
earth was flat these global warming
people are actually aligning themselves
with flat earthers by seeing that a
crowd agrees I think it's an
extraordinary thing it's not how science
advances and any scientist who speaks
about a crowd he's not a scientist at
all geez mic drop you don't even have a
microphone you can't drop your
headphones because then you couldn't
hear me yeah but but it's true I mean
it's just it's just an incredible thing
to do and I remember oh you know that
amazing writer and the guy who wrote for
an ER that beautiful doctor
who
eight of Kansas for whose name I won't
remember he said and then the Gasland
guy lied about it
consensus consensus is the last refuge
of scoundrels
on a sidenote before we go to break
because I realize I don't have enough
time to really get into that dirty
rotten scoundrels Michael Caine from
your neck of the woods one of my
favorite actors on my favorite films
ladder with Crowder we'll be back with
that McIlhenny hey if you enjoyed this
video subscribe by clicking my face or
click this video next to me it's playing
right now in a box how do we do that
that's the magic of the Internet is it
still playing still playing I don't want
to look at it it's still playing isn't
it